>>presenter: Hello, everyone and welcome to
another AuthorsGoogle event in the San Francisco
office. Today, we are extremely pleased to
have Dr. Michael Krasny. Dr. Krasny has actually
been to Google before in both the Mountain
View and San Francisco offices to talk about
his first book, "Off Mike". And he is, as
everybody in this room knows, and probably
most people who listen to NPR across the nation,
is the host of KQEDs award-winning Forum program,
a news and public affairs program that concentrates
on arts, culture, health, business, and technology.
The Forum is actually KQEDs most popular local
radio program that's produced in the San Francisco
Bay area and broadcast nationally. Since 1970,
Dr. Krasny has been a professor of English
at Stanford--pardon me-- at San Francisco
State University and he's also taught at University
of California, San Francisco and Stanford
University. He's also the recipient of numerous
awards and honors, including the S. Y. Agnon
Gold Medal for Intellectual Distinction, the
Eugene Block Award for Human Rights in Journalism,
the Inclusiveness in Media Award from the
National Conference of Community and Justice,
and the Koret Foundation Fellowship. Over
the years, Dr. Krasny has interviewed hundreds
of thinkers, writers, philosophers, atheists,
and believers. But despite discussing countless
controversial issues with his guests, he has
yet to find satisfying answers to life's biggest
questions. This led him to write his latest
book, "Spiritual Envy: An Agnostic's Quest",
which he will be actually discussing here
today. Please join me in welcoming Dr. Michael
Krasny.
[applause]
>>Michael Krasny: Thank you and thank you
for having me here. And try to get used to
this face with this voice, those of you who
know the voice through the medium of radio.
It's nice to be back here, at Google, always
interesting to me. I was saying just yesterday
on the air, we had a program some of you may
have heard from 9 to 9:30. It's one of these
odd couplings that we sometimes do in public
radio at your NPR affiliate. We spent the
second half hour talking about sea otters,
but before that, we talked about succession
in high-tech companies. And it seemed to me
to be one of those news stories whose time
had come, because Mackwell, who was in town,
but also because Steve Jobs going on temporary
medical leave again, as many of you know.
And because your own company, in April, will
change hands as far as the CEO leadership
and Eric Schmidt handing the baton over to
Larry Page. I think that may mean some interesting
changes, but we'll have to wait and see. I
hope it's all to the good. What we do every
morning, for those of you who are not familiar
with the program, is talk about news issues
and also talk to people who are news makers,
and certainly talk to people who are part
of whatever this zeitgeist is that's going
on. That is, tomorrow, for example, I'll be
talking with a novelist who’s originally
from Sierra Leone and be talking about shifts
in juvenile justice. This morning, we spent
an hour talking about President Obama's State
of the Union address and then talked with
Belva Davis, who is an African American icon
and legendary figure in the world of broadcast
journalism who's been at it for even longer
than I have. And that's what I do, day to
day. I mean, my other identity is as a college
professor and as a scholar, but I like when
I write books to go into different territory.
I mean, a lot of it's been scholarly territory;
I did write a book that I spoke about here
in Mountain View called "Off Mike", which
is essentially a memoir about both talk radio
and what I call "literary life," which amounted
to a self-expose of wanting to be a novelist
and failing and nevertheless, having the opportunity
to interview some of the greatest novelists
that are alive. This book was a very different
kind of book and it was a book, frankly, that
I didn't know I was gonna write and I was
surprised that I was writing. I started thinking
about what I believed or what I didn't believe
and thought, "Can I really get it down? Is
it something that I can explore? Am I gonna
be doing what I do day to day on the radio,
asking simply too many questions without having
answers?" I had a friend – I have a good
friend, who when he found out I was undertaking
this questioning, skeptical attitude about
what to believe as a magnum opus, or as a
writing project, he shook his head and gave
me a bit of pathos and said, "What are you
writing -- another scholarly book that has
no answers? Don't you know, Michael, that
book's not gonna make you any money." Well,
people want answers with books, it's true.
But they also, I think, especially many thoughtful
people and seekers and everything, are interested
in the kinds of questions and the kinds of
questions which maybe keep you up at night,
or did when you were a college student. My
publisher likes to call them "3 o'clock in
the morning" questions and I realize that
certainly, most of my adult life has not only
been asking questions on the air, but reflectively
and reflexively thinking about these questions
and maybe ruminating and mulling on them perhaps
more than one should divest one's consciousness
to do. I began with a line from a British
novelist that I particularly found compelling.
Julian Barnes, the novelist, if that name
means anything to some of you and it may,
I hope, who said, "I don't believe in God,
but I miss Him." And I found that resonated
for me in so many different ways because well,
frankly, after talking to and reading the
athiests, and there is, of course, a whole
new viral strain of militant atheists, Christopher
Hitchens and Richard Dawkins and others who
have really taken that position rather forthrightly
and presented a formidable opposition to organized
religion as well as, along with Richard Dawkins,
a very strong and scientific support for atheism.
And I found myself thinking about my interviews
with them and also thinking about interviews
I'd had with leading theologians and people
who had given themselves to lives of faith
and who had done some pretty extraordinary
things in light of their faith, or because
of their faith, or with their faith as a catalyst.
And I thought, "Is there some way between
this kind of polarized debate that has gone
on in our country now for well, generations,
but certainly in recent years, particularly
with the kind of intensity that had never
before been seen?" And I started grappling
with the larger question, "Is there a God?"
And I found myself asking even tougher questions.
"If there is a God, what's the nature of the
God?" and "Historically, how has God, as a
monotheistic or before that, in terms of polytheism,
Gods been viewed? Are there things we can
synthesize from that?" Because I like to think
of myself as a synthesizer. And I began to
ask questions that were even, in some ways,
more relevant because once you start thinking
about God, you find yourself thinking about
good and evil. You find yourself thinking
about these basic metaphysical questions:
Why we're here? What we're doing here? What
our purpose is here? Is there a reason for
our existence? And it began to be more than
contemplative; it began to be a quest. And
I realized that I came out of really a long
tradition of making this sort of quest in
terms of what I began to see as Agnosticism.
And Agnosticism is something that's almost
made into a joke. I mean, people of religion
make it into a joke because you haven't made
the leap of faith if you're an Agnostic; you
simply doubt and you don't know, or you say,
"I don't know." And Atheists find it, in many
instances, contemptible because you are hedging
your bets and taking what Pascal, Blaise Pascal,
the philosopher, called The Pascal Wager.
Pascal, who was a mathematician, but also
a philosopher, said, "The best thing to do
is to live a good, virtuous life because there
may be an afterlife. There may be Hell to
pay literally, or there may be rewards in
some kind of Divine sense. So, there may be
nothing also, but let's just hedge our bets
and do this wager and do it the right way
and be good." Because, certainly, most of
Scripture and most of religions have been
teaching us to try to be good and compassionate,
despite or notwithstanding, all of the dreadful
and horrific things that have been done in
the name of religion. And I had to grapple
with that as well because I realized that
there was a reason that gave birth to a lot
of the strong, militant atrain of Atheism.
It had to do with anger and indignation, and
a great deal of rebellion against what religion
had been. Particularly even recently, not
only because of 9/11 associated with religion,
but during the Bush Administration there were
many figures like Jerry Falwell and others
that young people particularly found themselves
contemptuous of and who felt that they didn't
really want to be identified with religion,
was identified with the Crusades and the Inquisition
and all these horrible things of carnage;
many wars ongoing. And so, many people nowadays
say, "Well, I'm spiritual, but I'm not religious,"
or, "I don't have a religion, but I'm spiritual."
And I thought, "What does that mean to be
spiritual? What is it, in fact, that we mean
by spirituality?" It's a signifier that the
great Derrida, the deconstructionist, post-structuralist
thinker, would call a floating signifier,
because it's very hard to get a handle on
what we mean by spiritual. A lot of people
simply talk about spiritual-like, maybe George
Lucas's the Force, or something that can't
really be defined. It's a quest for maybe
a higher meaning or more transcendent feeling.
So, all of this began to be, to come into
perspective and I found myself quarreling
with people of faith and quarrelling with
the Atheists, and finding not necessarily
a middle passage, but at least finding some
sense of a tradition of skepticism, which
goes all the way back, not only to Western
cultures, but to Eastern cultures, which simply
questions. Einstein said, "The thing is to
never stop questioning," and I began to really
accept that. And I began to realize that the
idea of a God, which is not palpable necessarily
to me or which I can't make the leap of faith
for, is by dint of history an idea that has
taken sway of so many civilizations, both
in the Western and Eastern world. Buddhism
has, to some extent, negated God, but there
have been Gods in Buddhism and there is the
idea of Buddha as a God incarnate. Almost
really every major religion has the idea of
a God. And I had gone through a phase, which
many young people do--I'm not a young person
anymore, but when I was a young person certainly--
of being nihilistic and thinking nothing has
any meaning. And I read "The Existentialist"
and thought, "That makes about the most sense
to me." Some writers, like Hemingway and Sam
Beckett and others, spoke to me personally
and it's a good pose to take that you believe
in nothing and nothing means anything and
we're all like Sisyphus, rolling that stone
up a hill for it to catapult us down and life
has no meaning and it's absurd and it's totally
irrational. And this is easy to wear as armor
for oneself. I thought, "No, I don't really
believe that." I did at one time, but I do
think life has meaning. I do think there are
things in life that can provide meaning and
what are those? You begin to grapple with
them on an individual level. They're different
to you than they may be to me, but nevertheless
they're worth exploring in a universal way.
And so, I thought, the real word that begins
to apply to what I am is "Agnostic". And I
once interviewed Studs Terkel, who said he
was an Agnostic, he was a great oral historian
and I said, "What do you mean you're an Agnostic?"
And he said, "Well, I'm a cowardly Atheist."
[laughter]
Maybe Agnosticism is a form of cowardly Atheism.
In fact, maybe Agnosticism has become a source,
because it has indeed for a lot of jokes because
of this kind of almost contemptuousness that
comes, as I said, from both sides of the continuum,
or the spectrum. Mort Sahl came up with the
great line that some Atheists moved into an
all-White, Christian neighborhood and someone
burned a question mark on their lawn.
[laughter]
And there's also that Woody Allen line about
an Atheist and an Agnostic who got married
and the marriage didn't work out because they
didn't know what not to bring the child up
in. Well, actually, I found myself saying,
"What is Agnosticism?" Aside from the sense
of a tradition that goes back, as I said,
to skepticism and before, in Eastern and Western
cultures, besides Socrates, who said, "The
only thing I know is that I know nothing,"
and some of our greatest thinkers coming to
that kind of conclusion, Agnosticism began
to resonate for me in different ways when
I began to study the Agnostics. And actually,
there are three. I call them, somewhat irreverently,
the Trinity of Agnostics. There are three
major Agnostic figures in the 20th Century.
One of them, of course, is Bertrand Russell,
a name many of you know, the Nobel Laureate,
mathematician, philosopher, who also called
himself an Atheist depending on what his audience
was. There was a man named Robert Ingersol
who was known as the great Agnostic, who was
a stunning orator and an attorney by profession.
And there was also another Agnostic by the
name of T.H. Huxley, who gave us the word
"Agnostic." He was known also as Darwin's
Bulldog and he was the grandfather of Aldous
Huxley, a name probably familiar to more of
you. But T. H. Huxley began to define Agnostic
in terms of not having Gnosticism, not having
secret knowledge, not simply knowing. And
he said, "You know what? I'm an Agnostic.
I call myself an Agnostic, but I'm open to
knowledge. In fact, I want knowledge. I seek
it. I welcome it. I would embrace it if I
have an understanding of what these Higher
Powers are, or these things that a priori,
I can't determine, that are beyond the metaphysical
realm, that is, above the physical realm,
the material realm. I wanna know what those
things are and I'm open constantly to the
possibility of being convinced of what they
are." And I began to realize that there were
some extraordinary and very-- I shouldn't
move away from the microphone-- significant
analogies between Agnosticism and the paranormal
because we explore the paranormal and we try
to find out if indeed everything happens for
a reason, as some people say nowadays, or
some things happen for a reason, or there's
synchronicity, or there's serendipity, or
there's psychic power that you have, telekinesis,
all these kinds of things. None of them have
been proven and there's, again, a strong skeptical
tradition that says, "Show me the proof,"
essentially, where these things are concerned.
And so, I began writing about the paranormal
as well and I began writing about spiritual
hunger, which I thought, is a real phenomenon
because I think people, and especially so
many of you who are young, want some sense
of answers, want to be able to name or be
able to find some sense of signifying meaning
that will give you purpose, that will give
you meaning, that will provide some elevation
of spirit or of faith or of vitality or ignition
in your life that you, perhaps, have been
looking for or are seeking maybe even more
than you know. And I found myself exploring
some other extraordinary lives. For example,
I was always curious about a man I interviewed
many years ago by the name of Brian Weiss,
who wrote a book called "Many Lives, Many
Masters". And he was a Princeton educated
– excuse me – a Yale educated MD, who
had been in charge of psychiatry at Miami
General Hospital and he believed that there
were former lives. And he had every sense
of conviction that former lives existed and
he would take patients and take them back
to their former lives; past life regressions.
Which, as a skeptic, of course I looked on
with some disfavor and skepticism, but I thought,
"What makes a guy like this tick?" I wanted
to figure him out. Bright guy, scientifically
trained and so forth. And I had the same question
about John Mack, who was a Harvard professor,
whom some of you may know, who is a Pulitzer
Prize winning biographer, in fact, of Lawrence
of Arabia, was a leading psychiatrist and
head of the Department of Psychiatry at Harvard,
who had taken all of these people who felt
that they had been abducted by aliens, put
them under hypnosis, and they were completely,
utterly traumatized by something that they
believed was alien abduction. And Mack was
saying, "There must be something there." And
again, I looked upon this with a high degree
of skepticism; still do. But I wanted to know
what made somebody as smart as Mack also tick.
What made him search for this meaning which
he looked for with these abductees? I also
brought into this particular triad of subjects
of interest, a man named Ian Stevenson, who
spent more time zealously trying to recover
data that proved, again, former lives because
there was evidence he felt that people had
died at a certain time and their souls had
transmigrated and they had gone into somebody
else's soul because there was this xeniglossy,
which is a whole phenomenon where somebody
can supposedly speak a language that they've
never learned or they've never grown up in.
And he had what he felt was incontrovertible
proof of xenoglossy. The proof doesn't convince
me, but I wanna know, again, what makes somebody
like that tick because I feel that all of
these men, brilliant men in their own ways.
And Stevenson, by the way, was Head of Psychiatry
at University of Virginia. You can conclude
from these three cases that all psychiatrists
can be mental cases, but I wouldn't do that.
[laughter]
That would be one syllogism. What I wanted
to find out is, as I said, what motivated
them? What compelled them? And I thought it
was spiritual hunger, and I began to look
at their lives, especially someone like Brian
Weiss, who had lost a child at a fairly young
age, and he and his wife were clearly in mourning
and grieving that needed some kind of meaning.
And frankly, why I call my book "Spiritual
Envy" is because spiritual anchoring and faith
can, and indeed often do, provide not only
meaning, but wonderful consolation. Whatever
you want to say skeptically or nihilistically
or to downgrade or to derogate the idea of
faith, or the idea of a spiritual anchoring,
there are people who find consolation and
there are people who get off of a life of
recidivistic felonies. I used to do work at
San Quentin with prisoners and I found that
those prisoners who adopted a faith, in many
instances, got out of a life of crime much
more than they would have under different
circumstances. I discovered through research
and doing a number of programs on this, that
there are many young people and people of
middle age and even older, who are addicts.
Addicts, in some instances, their whole lives,
who are able to give up their addiction because
of faith. I mean, faith doesn't necessarily
move mountains, but faith and belief and spirituality
can not only console bereavement, it can provide
an antidine or an antidote--whatever you wanna
call it-- or amelioration of some pretty severe
and serious and complex human problems. So,
I found myself, curiously enough, in this
ambivalent situation about faith, because
one has to concede the fact that religion
has been misused and abused and people have
done dreadful things in its name, but I also
began to think of what religion or what has
been done in the name of religion that's positive.
And I thought of the Abolition Movement and
the Civil Rights Movement and they were very
tied to religion. I thought of the Solidarity
Movement in Poland, which is essentially a
Catholic movement, and the Catholic Theology
Liberation Movement in South and Central America,
all trying to ameliorate poverty and all dealing
with social problems. And so, I wanted to
give that kind of unbiased-- what I like to
think I do as a broadcast journalist in my
better moments-- view of faith, religion,
spirituality, and what is behind them. And
yet, this book in many ways, is a personal
quest. It's a personal quest to try to find
out why I lost my own belief and what happened,
because I said Julian Barnes' line had such
an effect on me. And I didn't know what was
still stirring in me in terms of desire. And
I have friends who say, "Who the hell cares?"
The novelist, Jane Smiley, whom some of you
may know, the Pulitzer Prize winning novelist
who lives now in Carmel, said to me, "You
know, Michael, I used to be an Agnostic, but
now I'm an Indifferentist cause now I really
don't give a shit."
[laughter]
Maybe there's something to be said for being
an Indifferentist. But some of us can't just
give that up, that search, or give up that
desire to have a higher meaning or to have
some sensibility that will make sense to us
and will give order to our thinking or some
kind of pattern to our thinking that makes
maybe a more transcendent or higher and more
elevated sense. I thought, though, rather
than talk more about my book, I would read
a short passage because the book is very serious
and, as you can tell, it takes on some pretty
serious questions. But Eric Idle of Monty
Python once said to me in an interview, "There
are two forces in this world. There's gravity
and levity." Which I like to this day.
[laughter]
And I wrote a few things that I thought, I
guess I'm a frustrated novelist, so I wanted
to be a storyteller here as well, and I told
some stories and a few of them, I think, are
worth at least one, bringing to your attention
because I think it's pretty funny, and it
also gets to some questions about the paranormal
and about where skepticism and Agnosticism
play their role. It's also a story that I
simply like to tell, so I included it and
it's a short enough story that I'd like to
read it to you. But mainly I wanna read it
because it's funny. And I begin by saying
a funny and revealing story comes to mind.
This is about a quarter of the way into the
book.
[reads]
"I had an accountant named Bob Steiner, who
was also a magician. I like saying my accountant
was a magician. Steiner became rather well-known
in the world of skeptics and debunkers, and
he appeared many times on television and radio
as a bogus psychic. In fact, he worked with
the famous magician, James Randy, and he and
Randy exposed a phony faith healer named Peter
Popoff, who used an electronic device that
fed him information through an earpiece. Popoff's
wife would tell him, through the earpiece,
people’s ailments as he approached them
in the audience and he would amaze everyone
by noting, supposedly with help from God,
what they were suffering from, or where they
were in pain, or what they had been diagnosed
as having; all information acquired ahead
of time by Mrs. Popoff. Steiner happened to
mention to me that he was doing a television
show for the Fox Network based on the life
of Harry Houdini. He informed me that they
were going to do a séance, in which they
would attempt to get Houdini to speak from
the dead because Houdini had debunked many
séances and swore he would communicate from
the afterlife, if one existed.
[laughter]
"It all sounded like good entertainment to
me, and when I asked Steiner who was producing
the show, he told me it was a fellow named
Ken Ehrlich. Now, Ken Ehrlich had, at one
time, lived three houses away from me in Cleveland
and we had belonged to the same college fraternity.
My sister had been his babysitter when he
was a child and our parents were friends.
He had gone on to be the producer of the Emmys
and the Grammys, and Ehrlich had no way of
knowing I knew Steiner. Steiner had impersonated
a psychic on many occasions all over the world
as part of his debunking crusade, and he was
good at it. When set against others who claimed
they were real psychics, he inevitably got
audiences to believe in the superiority of
his psychic powers. Then he would reveal that
he was a skeptic--
[laughter]
"and a magician impersonating a psychic. I
asked him when he was planning to see Ehrlich,
and he told me they had a meeting set up for
a week later in Beverly Hills, and I proceeded
to reveal to him many facts about Ehrlich
that few people, except those from Ehrlich's
past, could know.
[laughter]
"When Steiner met with Ehrlich, then Erlich's
assistant producer, Steiner went almost immediately
into his psychic role, insisting right off
to two skeptical men that he possessed paranormal
powers. To the assistant producer, he made
general observations of that sort – of the
sort that anyone might buy into, and then
he told Ehrlich that he had never before felt
such powerful psychic vibrations as he felt
with Ehrlich. He started off by saying he
saw a diamond and couple of older people.
Did that have any significance? I had told
Steiner that Erlich's grandparents name was
Diamond. I had also told Steiner – excuse
me -- I had also heard from my mother, a few
months earlier, that she and my father, who
were still friendly with Ehrlich's parents,
had attended the bar mitzvah of his brother
Steve's son in Cleveland. Steiner asked Ehrlich
if he had a brother, and when he did, Steiner
asked if there was a recent celebration or
ritual having to do with the brother's son.
All this was pretty surprising to Ehrlich.
[chuckles]
"But he deduced that Steiner must have talked
to his wife.’You spoke to my wife, didn't
you?' Ehrlich asked. Steiner looked Ehrlich
right in the eye and sternly said, 'I swear
on everything, including my own life and the
lives of my children, that I have never met
or talked to your wife.' Whereupon he asked
Ehrlich another question gleaned from my supply
of information. Had Ehrlich dated a girl in
college with a peg leg?
[laughter]
"Ehrlich became, according to Steiner's description,
highly agitated--
[laughter]
"exclaiming that his wife did not know about
this girl who, unfortunately, had come to
be called 'Peg Leg Betty.'
[laughter]
"Steiner told me he felt compelled at this
point to let Ehrlich know the truth, because
Ehrlich was begging. Then Steiner blurted
out, 'Mike Krasny says hello.'"
[laughter]
A little bit of a quasi-charming story and
funny, but also revealing in the sense that
one can always present paranormal or parapsychological
as being real. And one can always make people
believe in ways that they didn't even think
they could believe, or would believe. They
might have think -- they might have thought,
as many do, that they had a strong enough
skepticism to be a bulwark against that, but
that was the point of that story. And the
point of this book is to really illuminate,
educate about Agnosticism; to talk in ways
that are going to be catalysts and have been
catalysts, I'm proud to say, to many really
wonderful conversations about the nature of
spirituality, about the nature of meaning
in life. And I can tell you this because I
am at that stage of life now where, unfortunately,
I can be called an Elder, and have been. I
discovered that whether you believe in something
or not, maybe is less important than how you
guide and what you do and what you accomplish
and what you set out do to and what you make
of your life, of course. And I know that sounds
trite and it sounds like a platitude, but
lemme put it into a context. When the great
African American playwright, August Wilson,
died, I was very moved to read that a reporter
who had talked to him only weeks before his
death--and for those of you who don't know,
he's the author of "Fences" and "Ma Rainey's
Black Bottom", and a number of works that
won him a couple of National Book Awards and
Pulitzers, both--he's a man who was, by the
way, I admired and was a tough interview;
a little bit surly and strong-minded in ways
that were almost slightly combative at times,
but nevertheless, I gleaned a lot from the
few times I got the privilege of interviewing
him. The reporter who talked to him before
he died was talking to him about life and
life's meaning and he knew that the death
sentence was hanging over him. In fact, he
thought he had a little more time than he
had left. He was dying of pancreatic cancer--the
severe kind. And he said, "You know, my life,
when I look back on it, has been so filled
with blessings and that's what I have to say
as I know I'm on death's precipice, as I know
I'm going into what Dylan Thomas called 'that
good night of death.'" And I thought whether
you believe in blessings or not, if you can
say that toward the end, then you're saying
a lot. You're saying an immense and abundant
sense of what life can mean and what life
ought to mean. And so, the realization that,
for example, to say to yourself at a certain
stage in your life, "I've lived a good life,'
whatever that means, and one hopes it means
a virtuous life, one hopes it means a noble
life, one hopes it means an ethical life,
but to say at a certain point that you lived
a good life, that you've made some kind of
contribution that's meaningful impact, that
you've been a good, decent, loving, compassionate
person, as opposed to saying, "Good or evil?
What's the difference? What's -- what does
it matter in the long run?" I mean, cause
a nihilistic view and a view of say, what
Dostoyevsky gives us in The Brothers Karamazov,
"If God does not exist, anything is permissible,"
is a legitimate intellectual view. There's
no gainsaying it, right? If you believe that
God should be involved in our human affairs,
for example, be that kind of omnipotent God
or a God who is entering into our lives, then
you have to wrestle with some very considerable
questions, such as evil and why it exists;
the question we call theodicy in philosophy.
That is, how can God allow for carnage? How
can God allow for horror, child molestations,
children being beaten and so forth, like in
Karamazov? Regardless of what your own answers
are, what a sense of compromise you may come
to, it seems to me, and I wanted to make this
case, in a polemical way that there is a case
to be made for living a good life, that there
is a case for choosing goodness. And in many
instances, it's very hard to even decide what
goodness is 'cause you know the road to hell
is paved with good intentions. You know that
sometimes when you choose to be good, it turns
out to be not good at all. And sometimes when
you choose to be not good and your own free
will is involved, goodness comes out of it.
So, it's always a challenge, especially with
the big questions in life. I remember interviewing
the Nobel Laureate, Issac Bashevis Singer,
and I said to him, "Free will in your work
means so much. Free will seems to mean everything.
Do you believe in free will?" And he said,
"I have no choice."
[laughter]
But I think maybe we don't have any choice
but to believe in free will and to believe
that choice is ours in many instances. Certainly,
you can feel that life is being shaped for
you, determined for you in forces that don't
allow for your own existential authenticity
or genuineness, but to a great degree you
have choice, you have will, and you have the
power of decision-making. And that means the
power to decide whether or not to do good,
or to be compassionate, or to be loving, or
to give service, or to do something that has
a mission to it that makes life a better place
for all of us. Thank you.
[applause]
I wanted to be brief because, obviously, this
is a topic that I can go on and on and on
about. But I found that when I give talks,
there are not only questions about the conversations
that I like to think the book and its content
starts, but there are usually questions or
comments about the work I do in radio, which
I'm certainly welcoming because the last time
I was at Google, the last two times at Mountain
View and here, there were a lot of questions
about what I try to do in the way of public
service day to day. So, whatever's on your
minds is certainly welcome. What I said was,
if any of you have questions or comments about
anything I've said related to my book, I'd
be certainly delighted to entertain them,
hear them, welcome them. These ideas about
spirituality and about search for God and
all have, it seems to me, been, as I said
earlier, catalysts to more questions and more
conversation and I welcome it from you. But
also, if you have questions or anything you'd
like to raise about. The Forum program and
I do on a daily basis, that's welcome as well.
So, you have free will here.
[laughter]
Yes.
>>audience #1: Have you done much exploring
in--
>>Michael Krasny: Pardon?
>>audience #1: Have you explored many spiritual
schools of thought? Have you pursued practices
of Buddhism or Islamic traditions or anything
of that nature and do your explorations get
closer to the answer?
>>Michael Krasny: Did everybody hear the question?
Have I explored other spiritual roots and
the answer is most affirmatively, I made a
lifetime study of religion, theology, philosophy
because it happens to be -- some people like
to listen to U2, I like to listen to and read
theology. I'm quirky that way, I guess. But,
a more important segment of your question
is, have I tried some of the practices? And
yes, because I think there's a lot to be said
for meditation. I think there's a lot to be
said for many of the Buddhist practices. I've
gone to Spirit Rock; Jack Kornfield's a personal
friend who was nice enough to write some wonderful
words about my book and I've looked into just
about every major spiritual form of transformation
and investigation. Have I embraced any of
them? No. Have I taken any as an anchor of
faith? No. Do I think that they can provide
meaning in people's lives? Absolutely. Yes.
>>audience #2: So, I have a question. It sounds
like this book is primarily about an individual’s
faith in God and lack thereof, but it seems
to me, I am British, so I come from a country
which basically gave up on Christianity about
40 years ago. And I grew up going to church
once a month because my parents--
>>audience #3: 400 according to the Pope.
>>audience #2: Yeah. Right. But the church
doesn't form a big role in Britain because
of--
>>Michael Krasny: No. No, many fewer Brits
go to church than Americans by far, by disproportionately.
>>audience #2: There's the state and the trade
unions and so forth, which provide a big social
staple structure of people who belong to.
Whereas, the States, I have friends from Tennessee
and so forth, and their parents, their families,
everyone belongs to the church because it's
kind of like the only safety net they have.
And so, do you address that or have you addressed
that there's this double-sided thing – there's
being the individual spirit you have but it's
also this big social role that the churches
play across the world in Islam and Christianity.
>>Michael Krasny: Well, it's a very good question
and I'll come at it from a couple of perspectives.
One is that churches, mosques, synagogues,
houses of worship really do provide community
for people. They also provide tradition; they
provide heritage. I mean, one of the things,
I guess one of the quarrels I have with the
atheists is they wanna throw the babies out
with the bathwater, and there are things,
obviously, that organized religion does provide
people. The Evangelical woman is still extremely
strong in this country about, believe it or
not, one out of six Americans identify with
that movement and consider themselves, even
a larger number then, that believe in Heaven
and Hell, certainly believe in God, believe
in Jesus and the Resurrection and so forth.
And what you find is the younger generation
-- there's a new book out in fact by Robert
Putnam, who wrote "Bowling Alone"; he was
on Forum, you can listen to the program--this
is not a plug--
[laughter]
but it's on iTunes and it's on the Web and
so forth; you can download it. But Putnam’s
really a good thinker and he did a lot of
research, a lot of deciduous research talking
to younger Americans who have been more eclectic,
taking Buddhist practice or taking forms of
spirituality of one sort or another without
necessarily joining a congregation, or belonging
to any kind of congregation or organized religion.
That seems to be part of the pattern in America,
but the pattern is still very entrenched with
religion. By contrast, in the UK, or much
of Scandinavia, which has become very Agnostic,
by the way, I mean Denmark, particularly,
but also Norway and Sweden, and to a lesser
extent Finland, these are countries that go
through all the rituals with religion, christenings
and confirmations and so forth, but they've
abandoned religion for the most part. I mean,
obviously Russia has abandoned religion, or
did under the Communist regime. The Chinese
have abandoned religion. Religion is not the
global force it once was, but in many ways,
of course, it remains an extraordinary global
force when you think of Islam and when you
think of Gnostic and Evangelical Christianity
and Arden Christianity, and particularly as
I think you suggest, in this country. But
when you're talking about the generation divide,
you're talking about something that's, I think,
quite real. And how young people reconcile
the strong faith of their parents with what,
for many of them, is a breaking away, is,
I think, an individual matter. Because you
hear young people saying, "Well, I'm getting
married and I'm having a priest, even though
I think this priest may have buggered somebody."
I mean crazy things like this.
[laughter]
I mean, there's all this ambivalence. In other
words, "I'm disdainful of religion, but at
the same time, I wanna do something for my
parents, so I have a priest marry us in a
same-sex marriage." No.
[laughter]
The sense of being fastened to the past and
wanting to please your parents and not wanting
to commit what, I'll harken back to a great
existentialist who is a nihilist, Jean-Paul
Sartre, not wanting to commit bad faith. That
is, not wanting to do something that goes
against your own authenticity is, I think,
a battle. It's a battle again of free will
and decision-making. I hope that provides
some light.
>>audience #2: I was more wondering about
could you have Agnostic church? Like, if you
wanna be Agnostic but you wanted to belong,
how would you set up an Agnostic church?
>>Michael Krasny: There are Agnostic places
of worship; there are Unitarian churches.
You know the joke about the--I write a lot
about the Ten Commandments—the joke about
the Unitarians is that they call them the
Ten Suggestions.
[laughter]
There are many forms of secularized worship
now and they're becoming, Kinderschules in
the Jewish religion, for example, which abandoned
any idea of monotheism, but want that sense
of heritage and want that ongoing tradition
that is imbued with Jewishness as opposed
to Judaism, which is very rooted in monotheism
and belief in God. There are Agnostic societies.
There are, in fact, AA, Alcoholics Anonymous,
used to say "I believe in a Higher Power.
I'm subject to that Higher Power's power,
all that," there are Agnostics and Atheists
who felt uncomfortable with that. So now,
there are Agnostic and Atheist chapters of
AA. So, yes. The answer is yes. Yes.
>>audience #3: [ ] often religious compared
to [ ] in a pejorative way, but one of the
things I found interesting about what you
were talking about is that you brought religion
and paranormal activity together through the
pursuit of skepticism and that our skepticism
as it relates to those two topics is very
similar. How did you find having discussions
about paranormal activity, what religious
folks did and were you able to navigate that
without triggering that sense of "Oh, you
just think this is all psychics and whatnot"?
>>Michael Krasny: Well, really deeply religious
people are extremely suspicious of the paranormal
because I have some friends, in fact, who
went around teaching yoga, and this isn't
the paranormal, but it’s a good example.
They were teaching yoga in elementary school
classes in places like Idaho and Nebraska
and parents were, the same kind of parents
who were really concerned about kids using
Ouija boards or maybe getting a little bit
too into Halloween or Black Sabbath or things
of that sort, these are parents who feel that
their kids' souls are at risk here. I mean,
whether it's yoga or whether it’s the paranormal,
they do feel that way. And I think you have
to have a sense of, at least sensitivity to
that, or respect that as much as you can.
There - what I found in this debate is there
is a dogmatism on both sides that I don't
like. That is, people of religion can be terrific
people; they go out and they do missionary
work and they try to help the poor and lift
up the struggling peoples of the world, sometimes
in ways that have been dastardly, to be sure,
but sometimes in really significantly merciful
and kind and decent ways. But too many of
them are off the scale in their dogmatism,
and are unwilling to be open to those of a
different turn of mind or belief system. And
the same has become true for many of the more
militant Atheists. When I interviewed Salman
Rushdie, for example, who has become an Atheist,
he said, "I'm an Atheist but when people say
public policy, I believe fetuses are life,
for example, therefore I don't believe in
abortion. I believe that all these abortions
are a Holocaust of human life." He said, "I
have to recognize that that comes out of a
faith-based belief. That's policies. I don't
feel contemptuous toward their belief, but
I embrace the idea that God does not exist;
the absence of God." And by the way, Stephen
Hawking just came out with a new book where
he said, "I'm no longer an Agnostic; I'm an
Atheist because the Big Bang probably had
gravity before it." And I thought, "Steven,
you may be the most brilliant man on the planet,
but you still gotta ask the question, how
did gravity get here?" Anyway--
[laughter]
if you talk to exceedingly religious people,
or exceedingly strong Agnostic – I mean
Atheist believers, Bill Maher is a good example
by the way. Bill Maher, if any of you saw
"Religulous" or if you listen to him or see
him on his show, he's really very contemptuous
toward religion and it’s that dogmatism,
I think Maher is a brilliant comic and I have
a lot of respect for him, but it's that dogmatism
that I enveigh against, that I am on my own
hobby horse enveighing against because I don't
think it's healthy. Look, this is a republic
that believes in freedom of religion, even
though the Puritans came here and they burned
witches and they punished Pagans and Indians
and all of that because they didn't conform
to their religious beliefs that they came
here to practice and believe in. But nevertheless,
it's a cornerstone of American belief. And
when I look back at the Founding Fathers,
and when I do that, I get very uncomfortable
because I begin to think, "Krasny, you're
sounding a little like Glen Beck"--
[laughter]
and Heaven forefend, if there is a Heaven.
But our Founding Fathers, for the most part,
I mean, Jefferson, Madison, Monroe, and everything,
they were deists. They believed that God maybe
created the Heavens and the Earth and then
He went MIA, or She went MIA, or something
went missing in action. And then it became
up to us to make this shining city on the
hill and this republic into a great and ideal
place. And one of the things that's been the
cornerstone of that ideal has been freedom
of religion, freedom to practice and be whatever
you wanna be, or not be. There were always
village Atheists and they were, in some instances,
really tarred and feathered and all that.
There were never village Agnostics. I tried
to trace that. I thought maybe, it was actually
almost an institutional phenomenon of the
village Atheists, but nevertheless, Agnostics
were looked on with less scorn than Atheists,
and they were a little more accepted. But
people of strong faith, and this is in our
own American literature, people of strong
faith looked down upon them and still look
down upon them. Yes.
>>audience #4: I just had a brief comment
on that end, both on the side of Atheists
and the church [ ]. I have a belief, after
years of listening to you on the radio, what
you look like.
[laughter]
I am struggling with this man, who does a
wonderful Michael Krasny impersonation, but
I believe he looks much different. So, it's
kind of neat to illustrate that.
>>Michael Krasny: Have you come to the conclusion
that I'm far more handsome than you had anticipated?
Yeah.
[laughter]
That's, that's always the reaction.
>>audience #4: Not the face for radio.
>>Michael Krasny: Well, sometimes it's a face
for radio, actually. Or, it feels like a face
for radio, but that's, that's kind of you.
And I like that as a metaphor because you
do have these notions in your mind. I mean,
some of you have a picture, probably, of God,
or you did when you were a kid; flowing beard
-- whatever the case may be. If there is
a God, and I'm not saying there isn't, it's
hard to prove it negative. But if there is
a God, he, she, it may look nothing like you
imagined, in the same way that you experienced
this phenomena of looking at me. For example,
I found myself also exploring the notion of
extraterrestrial life because I thought to
myself, "Here again is something we don't
know." We don't know what's out there in interstellar
space. We don't know what's out there in the
small planets that look like Earth or beyond
our galaxy; there's an infinite number of
galaxies. Like Carl Sagan used to say, "Billions
and billions." We may even -- I'm interviewing
Brian Green on Monday, both on the air and
at the Herbst Theatre, and some of you may
know his work, the string theorist, physicist
from Columbia and he's always been saying.
His new book is, in fact, making an argument
about parallel universes and all of that,
and they may exist, but we don't know. I mean,
that's what Agnosticism says ultimately. We
just don't know. Nancy Reagan said, "Just
say no to drugs," Krasny says, "Just say no,
I don't know," to some of these questions."
But we always thought that if there is life
out there, that it's life as we perceive it;
it's life, somehow, existing in oxygen or
some kind of atmosphere like our own. But
there may be life out there or some kind of
life as we don't know it. I mean, as a mystery
to something that we can't even conceive and
that, it seemed to me also, was a good metaphor
for just what you were saying about you have
an image in your mind of aliens. John Mack,
who I mentioned before, the Harvard professor
who thought all these people were actually
being abducted aboard spaceships and everything,
he didn't see the kind of data and research
that was done that showed that a lot of these
people who describe these aliens and everything
had these pictures in their minds once these
sci-fi movies started to come out and proliferate.
No accident, I think. These movies were being
made. There was an image of a certain kind
of alien. And people had that image in mind.
There may be aliens out there, but you don't
know what they look like, right? You have
no idea what they look like. Now we're told,
and this is why God has always been so anthropomorphic,
we're told that we were made in the image
of God. We're told that when you look in the
mirror, you can see, in fact, the image of
God. In fact, Voltaire said, "God created
man in his image, and man returned the favor."
[laughter]
It's a good line. But if there is a single
God, and by the way there's an argument to
be made that maybe the polytheists were right,
maybe there are many Gods. Maybe there's God
with a pitchfork in the ocean, Neptune, Poseidon,
Apollo driving a chariot in with the sun.
There's a new book out by Professor Dryfus,
whom some of you may know, he co-authored
with the Head of Philosophy Department at
Harvard [ ] where they make the argument that
we need to bring back a lot of that polytheism.
A lot of where we've gone wrong is with monotheism
because this God is such an angry God and
a vengeful God and there have been so many
things done in the name of war and aggression
in His name. And it was always His, His hegemony
and so forth. And I found myself thinking
that this anthropomorphic idea of a god may
have nothing to do with, if there is a God.
What that force may be. That force may play
no role whatsoever in our lives. It may just
be a primal force that began to create out
of some great Sargasso Sea of netherness,
what we now call our very small, little, blue
planet. Human life may be just one of those
strange accidents that came about, but you
always find yourself going back to those questions
of, "Well, if there was a Big Bang, what was
before the Big Bang? If there was gravity
before there was Big Bang, what was before
gravity?" And these are questions that, right
now, we don't have the answers to, and we
may never have the answers to. However, I
don't know how many of you know Tyson, who
is the host of NOVA, but he said to me in
an interview that, he said, "They're just
new frontiers, Michael. That's all they are.
They're just new frontiers that we have to
explore and that eventually we'll gain knowledge
about. We just don't have the epistemological
chops right now, but there's always, where
science is concerned, the possibility." Yes.
>>audience #5: Do you find the presence of
religion in certain theories in science, like
the string theory or multiverse?
>>Michael Krasny: Well, I do in string theory
to some degree because I think, and Bryan
and some of the other string theorists would
probably say as much, I think it requires
a certain leap of faith. I mean, if you're
gonna believe the hypotheses behind string
theory. I did something a number of years
ago, it was really quite a--I write about
it in the book—quite an extraordinary experience.
I was asked by a fellow named Phil Clayton,
who is a philosopher, to be an interlocketer,
an interviewer at Harvard at the Trinity Church
there, for those of you who know Harvard.
And it was a conference on science and the
spiritual quest. And what they did was they
got a hold of some of the major scientists,
both biological and physical scientists, internationally
of our era, who had some sense of faith, belief,
spirituality, or who were doing research that
seemed to bear out. And in most instances,
those were the scientists who came. And these
are a pretty brilliant group of people. Now,
most scientists are either Agnostics or Atheists.
That's just a fact.
[phone beeping]
But these scientists presented data, they
presented phenomenological research, they
presented all kinds of things that suggested
that there may be like, the Tao of physics
type of thing, if you read Fritjof Capra's
book, those sorts of things. A deeper possibility
of something spiritual behind what we can't
discern or make sense of. I wasn't convinced.
I remained the perennial, the inviolable skeptic
and that's where I remain. Yeah.
>>audience #6: Thanks for coming. Quick question,
when you were raised, you were raised in a
severely religious family – sorry if I missed
this in the beginning – were you Bar Mitzvahed
and was there an acute reason, person, or
incident that led you to change your religious
past or was it over a period of time?
>>Michael Krasny: Now, how did you know I
was bar mitzvahed?
[laughter]
You could probably guess that I was circumcised,
too, wouldn't you?
[laughter]
Yeah, I was brought up in a Jewish faith and
I was brought up in a way that answered questions
for me when I was younger. And told me that
there was something higher to believe in.
It was conservative Judaism, which is more,
in some ways, specifically observant than
reform. You know, the old Woody Allen joke
about the reform: My rabbi was so reformed,
he was a Nazi.
[laughter]
Dark humor.
I'll tell you what happened 'cause I write
about it in the book. It had nothing to do
with my later change and shift in beliefs.
In fact, I think I went through probably something
that many people have gone through. There's
nothing even that unique. I just had an intellectual
springboard in my life where I was reading
people like Nietzsche and Schopenhauer and
Darwin and Bertrand Russell and I realized
that I'd become a doubter. I didn't have that
faith that I wanted to cleave to, that I wanted
to hold fast to. And I missed it because I
think it is something to cherish, because
it gives you comfort and hope and certainty
and can give you real purpose. What happened
to me when I was a boy though, I write about.
And I've never talked about this and I'd never
written about this. It's funny, I interviewed
Belva Davis. You all know who she is this
morning? Belva Davis was the first black journalist
on the West Coast to be an anchor. She does
"This Week" in Northern California for KQED
television. She's an icon; she's a legendary
figure. She's 77 years old and she's a remarkable
woman who has been a kind of Walter Cronkite,
a trusted figure in broadcast journalism for
many years and has written a memoir. And she
wrote this memoir and decided, although she
had never talked about it, that she wrote
about being molested. Because it was important
in telling her story. And I was never molested,
but when I was a sixth grader, I was a young
kid with a lot of extroversion and desiring;
maybe I was even ADD, I don't know by today's
standards. I probably could've used some Ritalin;
had a lot of energy. It's all, I think, been
channeled in better ways than it was when
I was younger, but when I was younger, it
was being a class clown and acting up and
acting out. And I had a teacher who happened
to be a Brit, who had taught at the private
schools there, and some of the stories about
them are unfortunately true. And when I would
act up, or when I would act out, on a number
of occasions, he would take me, literally
by the ear, or by the scruff of my neck, take
me across the hall into the boy's room and
beat the hell out of me. I mean, we're talking
about slapping and kicking and on a couple
of occasions, at least, I remember one quite
vividly and then I remember there was another
one when he put my head into a toilet. I mean
its dreadful stuff. When you tell it as an
anecdote, it almost sounds funny or farcical,
but when you're a kid and you're going through
that kind of stuff, it's horrible, traumatic.
And I wasn't a stupid kid, so I decided, I
announced to my teacher one day and to the
class, like Richard Nixon did when he said
there was a new Richard Nixon, I said, "There's
a new Michael Krasny." It had nothing to do
with Nixon; that would be later. And I was
gonna be a good boy and not act up and I became
my teacher's helper and started cleaning the
blackboards and sweeping and doing all these
kinds of things. Trying to be a good boy,
trying to actually win his, to curry favor
with him so he wouldn't beat the hell outta
me. And what happened was, he asked me to
take a can of yellow paint to a sixth grade
classroom, right across the hall, the other
side of the hall. And it was a big can of
paint and I tripped and the paint went whoosh
down, like a small miniature river down the
hall. And he used to come out and also, aside
from beating the hell out of me in the bathroom,
he would go into the bathroom to have a smoke,
came out of the room to have a smoke, saw
me standing there looking forlorn with this
yellow river, grabbed me and gave me the worst
beating I ever had and made me mop up the
river. And I went home. As a kid, I kept the
tears in because if you cry and anybody saw
you cry, you were a sissy and that was the
worst thing to have to withstand. Again, if
there's a Heaven, Heaven forefend that any
one of your fellow boys in this working class
neighborhood I grew up in should see me cry.
But I went home and there was a little, wooded
area and I went into the wooded area and I
started sobbing. And I remember exactly what
I said. I said, "I was being good and God,
you know that I was being good. Maybe nobody
else knows. Maybe he didn't know 'cause he'd
beat the shit outta me, but You know that
I was being good." And that's how strongly
I believed in God. I believed in God with
that kind of fervor and that absoluteness
of belief, that I felt His presence. And to
lose that because it made sense to me that
I couldn't put into perspective that kind
of God any longer, years later. I mean, I
could remember even just a quick, funny story,
when I was about 14; there was a guy, a character
in my neighborhood who had – who invited
me over to look at pornography.
[laughter]
Which, a 14 year old kid can be a turn on,
obviously. Especially a testosterone-driven
kid, and he had all this pornography. Nowadays,
you just go on the Web. You have to do everything
you can to protect your children from going
on the Web, it's so ubiquitous. But at the
time, it was pretty verboten and interesting.
[laughter]
And then he said to me, "You have to swear
on your mother's life that you won't say anything
about what I'm about to show you." And, being
a curious kid and of course, interested, I
thought, "OK." He said, "Go ahead, swear on
your mother's life." "I swear on my mother's
life." "That you won't say anything about
what I'm going to show you." "All right."
Well, this kid, who we called Tweezer--
[laughter]
-- so the nicknames, the etymology of some
of these nicknames have been lost in antiquity.
Tweezer had a mother who you would call now,
a MILF.
[laughter]
And does everybody know what that is? OK.
Tweezer actually had photographs taken by
his father, of his mother, naked. He showed
me these photographs and I wanted to tell
all the guys in the neighborhood that I saw
Tweezer's mother in the buff. But I thought
if I do, my mother'll die.
[laughter]
Because I'd sworn and I'd taken this oath
on my mother's life. And I never even breathed
a word of this story until my mother was laid
in the ground, until she died many, many years
later, because that kind of belief can be
that strong. And it's not a belief, in other
words, that God is there and God is rewarding,
but God is punishing, too. And to lose it,
I'm not so sure it's a bad idea to lose the
punishment side of it, but to lose the reward
side of it, well, that's another story. The
toughest loss me for was the loss of the belief
that simply, that presence was there. And
that's what I grappled with. Thank you again
so much.
[applause]